Okay,
so there's a reason why it's not
uncommon for audio files to use steely
Dan records to test the sound quality of
new speakers.
The band is among the most sonically
sophisticated pop acts of the 20th and
21st century,
not just an audio fidelity,
but in the complexity of their jazz and
blues influenced songs.
Today I want to break down one of my
favorite steely Dan Songs,
Deacon Blues,
to show you what goes into making one of
these things and we might as well back
up and start at the intro,
which I'll play again,
so that is one of the most recognizable
intros and steely Dan's whole
discography because it features a unique
kind of court that's become a defining
feature of their music.
It's called the MIU major court.
They called it that,
a specific chord voicing that swaps a
second degree note for a tonic note in a
major chord.
For example,
if you take the c major chord,
c,
g,
C,
e,
and you switched the second c for a d
note,
you've made a c major chord and you can
hear a moon majors all throughout steely
dance music like in the first chorus of
black cow,
the chorus of don't take me alive even
right here in their first album on fire
in the hole,
and it should be noted that even though
steely Dan squeezed the miu major for
all it's worth this voicing has a
history that goes all the way back to
the twelfth century.
The first time it was ever used was
imperative.
The greats,
bitterroot ness.
Take a listen to the beautiful second
syllable of ness right here.
After these quintessential expressions
of the [inaudible] major chord,
the song dives into the first verse and
we begin to hear the story of a suburban
man in crisis.
Fantasizing about becoming an alcoholic.
Saxophone player.
Instrumentation includes a Rhodes piano,
a base that sort of floats along,
carrying the rhythm.
Larry Carlton steadily holding the
Melody on Guitar,
adding small frills which are hardly
noticeable but extremely important and
that they keep you from getting bored
with the progression while complimenting
vegans focus.
You have an acoustic guitar in there
too,
and the Great Bernard Purdie,
one of the best grooved drummers of all
time.
It's ordered.
Call me up
if you listen to Deacon Blues on
headphones or speakers,
and here just how good this music
sounds.
Every instrument has its own life.
Each sound is thick and close up when it
needs to be to achieve this Vegan and
Becker at were explicit and following
the example of legendary jazz producer
and engineer Rudy Van Gelder,
whose work at blue note records defined
a generation of jazz music.
Then Gilda was notoriously secretive
about his techniques,
but it's known that he had musicians
played very close to the microphones to
make his instruments sound warm and
intimate.
Anyone who's used microphones like the
one I'm recording this narration on
right now,
knows that every microphone has a
different quality of sound.
Steely Dan's producer,
Roger Nicole,
described his extensive microphone
collection in an interview once,
and the point is that the band
experimented exhaustively to get just
the right sound for each instrument and
vocal.
You can hear right there that when we
enter the second verse of Deacon Blues,
a horn section comes in,
composed by Tom Scott,
who detailed in a Washington Post
interview,
how he modeled his horns after Oliver
Nelson's or Kestrel style in which
middle register horns slide against one
another to create a thicker dissonant
sound.
Vegan insisted Scott include nothing in
the high end,
and for this reason,
when the bridge comes and the saxophone
solo happens,
personifying the main character of the
song.
It cuts through the mix like a lightning
bolt.
Because of the saxophone.
Solo is such an important part of the
song.
Fagan and Becker searched for the right
player to embody the sound.
One night they turned on the tonight
show with Johnny Carson.
Saw this
pete,
Chris lead to work your saxophone and
play what I feel very scotch whiskey all
night long guy behind the wheel.
And I thought you were talking about my
life.
So it was easy.
I just had to take one tape.
Instrumentation on Deacon Boone
is immaculate and complex,
but I think the lyrics are just as
important.
Deacon Blues tells the story of a
midlife crisis,
a man living a safe life in suburbia,
looking through the glass said gamblers
and wild ramblers seeing romance in the
million lights of the city at night.
He wants to be a saxophonist,
drink scotch whiskey,
die behind the wheels.
Deacon Blues is a song of existential
desire,
a desire,
as Becker says,
for one of those mythic forms of loser,
dumb and opposite to the routine middle
register existence that stretches life
to a thin film of small significance.
Fagan and Becker have always been
sardonic and Rye songwriters,
they're smooth,
jazzy feel stands in direct,
almost mocking opposition to the punk
rock sound that was gaining popularity
at the same time,
there's always a detachment in their
songs and uncertainty about exactly who
they're making fun of.
For example,
they came up with the name of the Song
Deacon Blues by recognizing how
ridiculous it was to give sports teams
majestic nicknames like University of
Alabama's crimson tide.
This mocking tone has turned a lot of
people off to their music,
but Deacon Blues I think contains a
hidden earnestness in the lead into the
first chorus.
The narrator says he's ready to cross
that fine line.
The line between his existence and the
one he wants to have.
The song suggests that he's tried before
and failed,
but the music place these lines like
he's taking a running headstart
barreling toward a chorus that explodes
into the fantasy.
I'm ready to die.
For this reason,
I think you can look at Deacon Blues as
a kind of literature.
The story seems to be the central
component here with each element of the
music,
filling out nuances and the main
character is fantasy to the point where
it's unclear in the last verse whether
the narrator has actually done it or
it's just been caught up in the dream.
I think listening to steely Dan with
some good headphones,
rewards close reads like this.
The layers are all there for you to
examine one by one or simply enjoy in
their combined expression.
The quality is great.
The composition is complex and the
lyrics are interesting and dense for me.
All of that adds up to a song that is
going to last.
Hey everybody.
Thanks for watching.
I love steely Dan and I love this
because I've never analyzed a song
before and I love trying new things.
Special thanks to the Washington Post
and to Howard writes,
work on the moon,
major chord and steely Dan such stuff
there from both those guys.
I linked them below.
Want to give him a special thanks.
I want to tell you guys about a channel
that I really love.
It's called wisecracker.
You can see it right there.
They do video essays like me and we've
been pushing to each other because I
think if you like my stuff,
you're definitely gonna like there's.
They do thug notes,
earthlink,
son,
and an eight bit philosophy.
There's really great funny work,
so click over there.
Watch one subscribed.
I know you guys are gonna.
Love it.
I have to catch a plane right now to
Pennsylvania because I'm about to give
my first ted talk.
Excited and nervous and I'll see you
guys on the other side.